i i was saddened by it and uh and also
you know i know that there are things
going on in will's life and his
relationship and it's a complex world i
see it as a larger issue and it's an
issue
of of the boundaries being broken you
know boundaries and allowances and
permissiveness to certain behaviors you
know and uh the fact is that that that
license is is being given to people to
act out violently when they don't like
what they hear i also think that people
not unlike will
or
myself
we live in a lot of pressure
you know
we set up a lot of pressure for
ourselves we're encouraged by this
country to never stop and never be
satisfied and never look at our lives
and going you know what i'm enough i
have enough
you know i've done enough
i don't need
nine businesses i don't need to be a
movie producer director writer actor
star
and have a record company and be on tick
tock and be on social media and have a
reality show and share my innermost life
on some therapy show
it's
beyond our bandwidth
and we're starting to see the symptoms
of what it's like to be on be living
beyond your bandwidth and cracking under
the pressure that's what that was
it was more than just an insult to
someone's wife jade is a tough girl she
can defend herself she wasn't being
physically attacked what that was was
someone who's
you know beyond the bandwidth and in
that moment he thought more about how he
was looking in that moment then what was
the right thing to do
and i don't condemn him for it it's just
wrong